and speaking of big pebbles this is
precisely the time for the story of
the week by claude askolovitch come in
come in claude welcome no a little
pebble claude askolovitch who is going to
take us to the united states and claude
you are much more balanced than
donald trump that's what we claim
but it's in the united states before we
ask ourselves a question about our history in
fact and this question is what the
summer president of the united states
of america is crazy hello the nautic
this is for you, dear anne-elisabeth,
here it is, and this is a question that
really arises for very serious
clinical psychologists or psychiatric doctors
who met yesterday
at yale university to find out whether for
the greater good of  humanity
should not take this crazy man out of the
white house
there is already a petition which claims which
was signed by several thousand
people since February
it is necessary to understand this the gray matter
of giving ump become a s  subject of
perfectly banal debate or conversation
in the united states and among the worried there
are even two schools so there votive that we
first renault it would be crazy and a
clue that it's not really
donald trump's fault
but simply this  70-year-old man
would be in the process of becoming prematurely
senile sorry, that is to say that he would
present warning signs
see the first signs of
senile dementia or Alzheimer's disease
that is the thesis that is  defended by
a thirty-year-old probably nothing and a
brilliant thirty-something his name is dévide
pac man he on a television show
where he had already explained once that
in our soul probably did not know how to
say and there he has sticks it's  rather
alzheimer he methodically exposed
all the oddities of the president
as so many signs
then his limited vocabulary his use
and abuse of children's words great smar
good bad his lack of inhibition his
incoherence and even his dizziness  because
he is dizzy sometimes all this
would show that evil has already seized his
brain and if you want to play
on this set we too are therefore looking
for signs of decay in trump for
example this somewhat empty look of a man
lost in his world is in his bubble
when this poor merkel gala
wanted to shake his hand or else this
way he recently had of recounting
the Syrian bombardment he was
eating the best chocolate cake
with the chinese president
when all of a sudden it took him and except
when he told the story on fox
news
he said he bombarded me do
n't miss the series who remembered it more
doting or crazy about nantua ain do your
games ladies and gentlemen
one thing commen only in america it
's america when we talk about free
speech freedom of expression it's
something different from us when we treat a
politician of background we do
n't do it seriously uh  yes now we
can  ut also resist this fascination
and wonder why this
conversation about trump's possible folio folio
took so easily
is it because this man is
really weird or because the
politics he claims to pursue at this point
different from this  what do the
enlightened progressive elites believe that basically,
to reassure themselves,
this man has to be mean
or completely crazy since he refuses,
for example, to fight
global warming,
a monster or a crazy person is more
reassuring, a crazy person and there he tells us  must
answer another
essentially democratic question
in the past in the soviet union we sent
dissidents to mental asylums who refused to admit the
perfection and beauty of communism
so of course lure it was a
dictatorship and we are democracies
and those who gloss  on
trump's brain are the self-proclaimed epitome
of progressive and democratic enlightened elites
except to want to  any force to make
of your adversary
a bastard a madman a madman a dodder
and considered that the voters therefore
voted for a bastard a fool one of a
dodder are we still in the
lucidity or already in contempt of
classy
good at the same time he is also weird
whitewashing his complicated name that in
the united states there was a lot of work
that was done on reagan from 94
and in particular on semiology says
what we could prove and what was
subsequently demonstrated that he was
really ill and by the
junior vocabulary we saw that in these words he was
waiting for ends with the words that
rhyme and with the words he uses
he has decided that at this time there  the
disease had touched him and therefore by the
vocabulary which employed it one could
measure the slightest word which during know
that means that it is not a question
which scientifically and completely
apart from asking the question of
mental health
today  today science was elected in 1  981
there in this case has not yet
healed a brand new president
is indeed measuring in the light of
what has been said about others we can
measure quantify and see for a moment
it is an impoverishment  vocabulary
of speech reflexes and a colleague
while I'm going to break you
right-wing presidents in a
historic government in
French political history we have the beds
of French political observers a
guy who keeps his word he applies his
electoral program
he is either  mad be dodder then
me people who take responsibility
for sending missiles have come
across saying that the musician see there i am
also dodder the cart on the a6 is
contagious
because it does not conflict someone who
takes  the responsibility of going to an
act of
war over what they said they
were going to do but wait for
commissions well i wish
more french politicians were to
break them and she  respect the word of the
fia and get the runner up he was elected
for that
he fulfilled his word obviously it's
a threshold to some dictators who will be
worrying if respected their word when
I come to power grant you the
haganah would be  not elected don't worry
doctor yakana watch there is the
diagnosis of lékana yes so donald
trump has a memory lapse this disease
there I forgot his name it rhymes with
twitter alzheimer the rumor
thank you and cana